you know I mean I never say never you
know but I mean I remember I mean I've
sort of a amateur chess player it's what
I'm interested in chess and I remember
back in the day when computers were
first being taught to play chess that
people would said that they would never
be able to beat the real great that the
grandmasters you know and the world
champions and and for a long time that
was true that the the the world champion
players that the great grandmasters were
able to you know to overcome the
computer not true anymore no it's not
true anymore the computers are certainly
as good if not better as any human
player as computer memory and
sophistication has increased you know
its outstripped human memory and
sophistication so so I don't know
everything it seems to me the thing that
makes a writer a good writer you know is
not just the technical skill with
language not even being able to find and
tell a good story you know it seems to
me that first of all there's a
relationship with language that the best
writers have which is very much their
relationship you know we if we read
Hemingway we know it's Hemingway that
that's it that because he has a
particular relationship with the
language and if we read James Joyce or
William Faulkner we know it's them and
if we read Garcia Marquez you know same
thing so that's the first thing is when
I'm looking at work I've tried to see
what is the relationship with language
and and the second the second things are
you know how you see the world but you
do you have a good ear I mean are you
good at listening to how people really
speak do you have a good eye are you
good at at seeing the world in an
interesting way you know and then
finally you're the greatest writers the
best writers have a vision of the world
that is personal to themselves they have
a kind of take on reality you know which
is theirs
and out of which their whole sensibility
proceeds you know now that to have all
of that in the form of artificial
intelligence I think it's quite it's
quite I don't think we're anywhere near
that yet but but what is true I think is
that there's beginning to be some sense
of AI as developing and a moral sense
developing an ethical and ability to
make good and bad good and evil choices
right and wrong choices you know and
that's a that's a step on the way to
words being what one would call human so
I mean I'm not saying never I'm just
think I don't see that we're there yet